نبدا النشره من تركيا حيث لا تزال البلاد
تشهدها الفداديه تقض مضاجع الاتراك زلزال
الامس هو الاشد منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في هذا السياق مشاهدينا اعلنا
مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبي عن هزه جديده
بقوه خمس درجات فاصله سته على مقاس ريختر
ضربت وسط تركيا صباح اليوم من جهتها اعلنت
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه اباد
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلازل الذي بل الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوبي البلاد الى ثلاثه الى
ثلاثه الاف وثلاثمائه قتيلا هو عدد
المصابين الى 20 الفا وعشرين
قتل
2921 من مواطنين عدد الجرح لدينا هو 15
الفا وثمانمائه واربعه وثلاثون كانت هناك
طلبات مساعده ودعم من 65 دوله حتى الان
وسننقل هذه الفرق الدوليه الى مناطق
الكوارث عندما يصلون تماشيا مع الخطط
المعمول بها